Now that you've seen
a bunch of activities for
the define stage, I want you to practice
breaking down an overall product
experience into much simpler steps.
Your task is to create a golden path for
users to successfully
use the shopping app.
Now, keep in mind the golden path
should only have the main or
the essential steps that a user takes to
find the real value that they came for
the product in the first place.
Supporting threads,
such as editing orders or
creating accounts,
are secondary to the golden path.
You can include those, but
they're not really essential for
the main tasks that the user
would need to perform.
And remember that you should be thinking
in terms of stories rather than pages.
This helps you prioritize the central or
the key user journey.
So go ahead and create a Golden Path for
the Super Duper Shopping App.
Keep in mind the previous personas,
the first tweet, and
the one page executive summary.
You can see the Instructor Notes for
these materials.
Once you're ready,
check this box to continue.